[Música]
deportes en directo América hoy me
acompaña el versátil Luis Méndez dije
deportes Perdóname Luis porque usted
como hace deporte y economía ya me
tienen aquí vuelto un ocho vamos a
hablar entonces de economía comenzamos
hablando de México Porque en ese país
hubo una reducción de la tasa de
desempleo Luis Así es Raúl esto se dio a
conocer luego de presentarse la encuesta
Nacional de ocupación y empleo nacional
desde un 4.5% registrado en el mismo
periodo del año 2020 en números la
población desocupada se sitúan 2.2
millones de personas entre los mayores
de 15 años y más la población económica
6.6 millones de personas lo cual
representa un aumento de
3.49 millones si lo comparamos con el
mismo periodo de un año antes lo
negativo de esta situación es que los
ocupados en el sector informal Mostrar
un crecimiento de 2.16 millones de
personas hasta ubicarse en 31.6 millones
es decir un
55.8% de la población ocupada el informe
revela que un alto porcentaje elabora en
condiciones críticas y no cuentan acceso
a instituciones de salud
esto refleja que la mayor parte del
empleo que existe en el país no es de la
mejor calidad si bien el número de
afiliados al IMSS presentó un
comportamiento bastante positivo en 2021
este obedeció a los cambios en la ley de
subcontratación de personal que
introdujo al sector formal un número
importante de personas que no estaban
afiliadas al instituto
Afganistán protestan en contra de los
recursos que pretende destinar el
gobierno de Estados Unidos para las
víctimas de los ataques del 11 de
septiembre vale recordar que está en
cuenta con alrededor de 9.000 millones
de dólares en activos en el extranjero
entre ellos siete mil millones en
Estados Unidos a manifestación se llevó
a cabo al occidente el país y allí piden
una compensación en Estados Unidos por
los daños causados por la guerra de más
de 20 años recursos
afgano Pero escuchemos qué dijeron
alguno de los manifestantes
a la nación no a ningún gobierno
2021 de acuerdo con la empresa este
beneficio neto fue de 4213 millones de
euros una cifra qué contrasta con las
pérdidas de 1133 millones que fueron
registradas un año antes la recuperación
se vio sustentada en el volumen de
entregas de aviones y en el negocio de
helicópteros las ventas se situaron en
52,149 millones de euros es decir 4% más
que en el año 2020 los datos le
permitirán el grupo
accionistas con una propuesta de 1.5 €
por acción de acuerdo con la pu
Luis cómo están los indicadores Los
indicadores de la jornada se muestran
mixtos en gran parte de Asia y también
en Europa todo esto por los la atención
que existe entre Rusia y Ucrania luego
de los comentarios de Estados Unidos
vemos en Asia como destacó el índice de
Shangai pero cayeron Tokio y también la
bolsa de Hong Kong en Europa
se está desarrollando una operación
mixta a lo largo de la jornada Luis
gracias entonces por toda la información
económica vamos a pasar ahora a ver
nuestro reportaje del día